We know from the California experience
what does climate change means maker
drugs for us exactly 40 years ago, I
discovered the greenhouse effect
chlorofluorocarbons or CFCs. These
pollutants were used those days as
refrigerants and as propellants
in spray cans. Until then, scientists
thought carbon dioxide from fossil fuel
was the one man-made greenhouse gas. My work showed these CFCs, they're more than
10,000 times more potent than carbon
dioxide. So how much pollution are we
dumping into the air every year? Close to
50 billion tons
of pollutant gases are dumped in the
atmosphere. I made the prediction in 1980
that the greenhouse effect should be
detectable by the year 2000 and the planet
started warming significantly past 2000, so the prediction was confirmed. So come 2010,
the warming will take off and reach values
which we have not seen in the last few
million years. Can we do anything to stop
this warming and bend the curve twenty years from now
and stop the warming reaching catastrophic climate?
Fortunately we can! We have the science
and we have the technology. Take the University of California, San Diego. We generate
our own power by solar, fuel cells and using methane from water treatment plants.
They're off-the-shelf technologies. There is no reason these cannot be deployed for the rest of
the nation and for the planet.
If you want to see more Figure 1, check
out our previous episode here and don't
forget to subscribe!